Grüezi miteinander.
Wir sind die beiden Autoren
des Films "Die Schere -
Der Graben zwischen Arm und Reich".
Er regte zu vielen Diskussionen an -
auf YouTube und in der Community.
Das freut uns sehr.
Es war ein Ziel von uns.
Wir nahmen auch
an der Diskussion teil.
Wir haben uns alles genau angeschaut.
Uns hat v.a. gefreut,
dass ein Q&A-Video gewünscht wurde.
Das möchten wir gerne machen.
Wir möchten euch live
noch ein paar Fragen beantworten -
nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen.
Wir kommen zum ersten Kommentar.
Der ist von Kathrin Schwarzbach.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt
und ein wichtiger Hinweis.
Ich gehe auf den Schluss ein -
die Familie mit den 13'000 Fr.
Wir haben bewusst
eine Familie gesucht,
die ein hohes Bruttoeinkommen hat.
So kann man
anhand des hohen Einkommens zeigen,
was das Ende des Monats
ganz genau heisst.
Und zwar,
wenn man nirgends Subventionen
oder Unterstützung bekommt.
Der grösste und auffälligste Posten,
das kommt im Film vor,
sind die über 3'000 Fr.
für die Kinderbetreuung.
So wird ein grosser Teil
des Bruttoeinkommens vernichtet.
Wir haben
nicht so explizit aufgezeigt,
dass die Familie
durch das grosse Bruttoeinkommen
die Möglichkeit hat,
in die dritte Säule a einzuzahlen.
Das ist ein Luxus,
den sie sich leisten.
Sie zahlen je ihre 500 Fr.
in die dritte Säule a ein.
Ende des Monats bleiben der Familie
mit inzwischen vier Kindern
noch 500 Fr. übrig.
Das ist der Punkt.
Es hat
mit der Progression der Steuern
und den Subventionen,
die wegfallen, zu tun.
Es gibt viel zu diskutieren.
Auch wir finden:
Wenn man mit 13'000 Fr.
in der Schweiz
kein gutes Leben mehr führen kann,
ist vielleicht etwas faul.
Aber dazu kommt:
Die Wissenschaft zeigt auf, dass der
Mittelstand an diesen Punkten darbt.
Sie sagen von sich selbst ja nicht,
sie seien arm.
Darum ging es nicht, im Gegenteil.
Es sind Leute
mit einem hohen Einkommen.
Aber man sieht gut, welche
Belastungen auch solche Leute haben.
Wir haben mit vielen Familien
in einer ähnlichen Situation
gesprochen.
Alle erzählten uns
ähnliche Geschichten.
Wir haben nicht nur mit
Familie Schneider-Riehle gesprochen.
Am Ende wollten die meisten aber
nicht öffentlich darüber erzählen.
U.a. weil man sich so von
seiner verletzlichen Seite zeigt.
Ich glaube aber durchaus,
dass Leute,
die in den Agglomerationen
der Städte wohnen ...
Die Mieten sind hoch,
die Krankenkassenprämien auch.
Das zeigt auch die Forschung.
Ursina Kuhn sagt z.B.,
dass die realen Haushaltseinkommen
von Mittelstandfamilien
in den letzten Jahren
eher stagniert
oder sogar gesunken sind.
Zum nächsten Kommentar.
Wir haben ganz bewusst keine Familie
oder Person porträtiert,
die von der Sozialhilfe lebt.
Gerade in den letzten Jahren
gab es mehrere Filme
im Schweizer Fernsehen,
die solche Personen gezeigt haben.
Wir haben jemanden gesucht,
der sehr wenig Einkommen hat,
aber sich gerade noch durchbringt.
Eine alleinerziehende Mutter
ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Gerade alleinerziehende Elternteile,
es sind nicht immer nur Mütter,
sind zu einem grossen Prozentsatz
betroffen
und müssen
mit sehr wenig Geld auskommen.
Wir wollten aufzeigen, welche
Probleme eine solche Familie hat
und wie sie das meistert.
Zu einem nächsten Diskussionspunkt.
Dazu möchte ich selbstverständlich
auch etwas sagen.
Insbesondere bei dieser Dokumentation
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
dass Herr Hess
als böser Reicher dargestellt wird.
Er ist einfach
ein vermögender Unternehmer.
Die anderen Reaktionen,
ebenfalls aus der Community,
fanden eher, dass Herr Hess
sympathisch daherkommt.
Es ist ein Hin und Her.
Ihr könnt euch
eure eigene Meinung bilden.
Wir wollten ganz sicher nicht
den bösen Reichen darstellen.
Aus unserer Sicht
ist uns das gelungen.
Der nächste Diskussionspunkt
von F V:
Eine sehr gute Frage.
Den Leuten ist es oft peinlich,
zu sagen,
wie viel oder wenig
sie wirklich haben.
Besonders beim Mittelstand
haben wir es gemerkt.
Wir hatten grosse Mühe,
Leute zu finden,
die eigentlich gut verdienen
und offen darüber reden wollen.
Es ist und bleibt ein Tabuthema.
Weshalb das so ist,
können wir nicht beantworten.
Oder hast du noch etwas dazu, Adi?
Den Grund
kann ich auch nicht benennen.
Bei unseren Recherchen haben wir
mit sehr vielen Leuten gesprochen.
Wir haben gemerkt, dass viele
nicht über Geld sprechen wollen.
Darum sind wir unseren
drei Protagonisten sehr dankbar.
Sie haben sehr offen und ehrlich
über Geld gesprochen.
Auch Herr Hess,
der sehr viel Geld hat.
Es ist bestimmt auch schwierig,
darüber zu sprechen,
ohne das sich Leute darüber ärgern.
Genauso wie Sonja Oberer,
die sehr wenig verdient.
Armut ist immer noch ein Tabuthema,
mit Scham behaftet.
Auch die Mittelstandfamilie
Schneider-Riehle
hat offen darüber geredet.
Wir sind froh,
dass wir Menschen gefunden haben.
Es war tatsächlich schwierig.
Es braucht diese Menschen aber für
so einen Film und eine Diskussion.
Wenn wir keine Menschen
finden würden,
die sich so offen zeigen, könnten
wir keine solchen Filme machen.
Darum sind wir froh und dankbar
über diese drei Familien.
Ein nächster Diskussionspunkt
von Stefan Herzog:
Ich muss vorwegnehmen:
Es war geplant,
diesen Film im März zu beenden.
Sogar noch etwas früher.
Er sollte vor der Sommerpause
ausgestrahlt werden.
Wir wurden auch von Corona überrollt.
Wir mussten unterbrechen und konnten
den Film nicht wie geplant beenden.
Wir mussten updaten.
Wir machten ein Corona-Update dazu.
Das Besondere an diesem Film:
Alle drei Protagonistinnen
und Protagonisten
sind unserer Meinung nach relativ
positiv durch die Krise gekommen.
Familie Schneider-Riehle hat es
geschafft, ein Haus zu kaufen.
Sonja Oberers Kinder
machen alle eine Berufslehre.
Sie konnte
einen zusätzlichen Job annehmen.
Hermann Hess hat Corona
am meisten zu spüren bekommen.
Seine Schifffahrtsgesellschaft
war zeitweise lahmgelegt.
Aber auf der andere Seite gab es eine
Wertsteigerung bei seinen Immobilien.
Bei den Geschäftsimmobilien musste er
aber sicher auch Abstriche machen,
da Geschäfte nicht zahlen konnten
oder Konkurs gehen werden.
Das ist bei ihm das Risiko.
Es sind aber drei positive Beispiele.
Niemand wurde porträtiert, der sehr
stark unter der Krise gelitten hat,
wie das in anderen Berufsgattungen
der Fall ist.
Wir wollten keinen Hass schüren.
Das wollten wir
mit dieser Doku nicht.
Und das haben wir auch nicht gemacht.
Eine weitere Frage von Ivan Schmid:
Da hat Herr Schmid insofern recht,
als dass er
Zahlen der ganzen Welt nimmt.
Wir haben die Situation
in der Schweiz speziell angeschaut.
Die Forschung sagt,
dass die Vermögensschere
v.a. nach oben grösser wird.
Unten, bei den Leuten mit weniger
hohem Einkommen und Vermögen,
bleibt sie relativ stabil.
Es wird sich zeigen,
wie Corona sich darauf auswirkt
und ob der untere Teil auch absinkt.
Aber im Moment ist es relativ klar.
Das gilt aber nicht für die ganze
Welt, sondern nur für die Schweiz.
Kommen wir
zu einem ganz interessanten Punkt,
der uns auch etwas schmeichelt.
Jürg Suter schreibt:
Vielen Dank für dieses Lob.
Das freut uns sehr.
Vielleicht
wird es einen zweiten Teil geben.
Wir wissen noch nicht,
in welche Richtung der gehen wird.
Ein spannender Aspekt wäre, und
das wird im Film auch angesprochen,
was Geld und Bildung
für einen Einfluss haben.
Der Grund dafür, dass sich die Schere
beim Mittelstand weiter öffnet,
ist ein schwieriger Aspekt, den wir
nicht so schnell behandeln können.
Das könnte man in einem Film
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen.
Danke,
dass ihr dieses Video geschaut habt.
Es freut uns sehr.
Habt ihr Interesse
an solchen Videos und Filmen,
abonniert
den YouTube-Kanal von SRF DOK
Dort gibt es
viele andere, grossartige Filme.